les savoir faire de la monnaie de paris
vous accompagne en terre de france
[Musique]
cette semaine on va partir à la
découverte de saint quentin en yvelines
12 communes qui composent à cette ville
nouvelle alors on va partir en balade
avec daniel on va aussi découvrir le
théâtre
et puis on a de la chance aussi parce
qu'on est accompagné par des copains de
tv 78 on va avoir plein de belles images
[Musique]
je m'appelle charlotte et je trouve
qu'on vit dans un pays formidable
les terroirs la gastronomie les paysages
mais ce que j'aime le plus sans doute
scellé rencontre si comme moi vous êtes
convaincus que les plus belles
découvertes se font souvent au bout de
la rue alors nous sommes faits pour nous
entendre
[Musique]
bienvenue à saint quentin en yvelines
situé à l'ouest de paris tout proche de
versailles
cette ville nouvelle a été créée dans
les années 70 en regroupant des communes
qui sont aujourd'hui au nombre de douze
mais au fond une ville nouvelle qu'est
ce que c'est à quoi ça ressemble pour
répondre à mes premières questions j'ai
rendez vous avec daniel un habitant
passionné par cette ville étonnante
derrière c'était combien de temps vous
maintenant un peu plus de 40 ans sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
où début j'étais plutôt sur elle en
cours puis après
ça fait 25 ans peu près je suis sur le
secteur montigny parce que le centre se
construit vous l'avez évoluer cette
ville
ici on est où exactement alors là on est
vraiment au centre au coeur de la
convergence de tous qui s'organise sur
le centre de saint quentin
on est dans un parc qui était conçu par
denis caravane qui est un concepteur qui
a notamment fait les axes majeurs de
cergy pontoise qui connut aussi mis
quelqu'un qui est il traite les grands
espaces fin des grands espaces et nous
sommes là au coeur du au coeur du
système c'est à dire derrière nous il ya
un grand axe qui va jusqu'au vélodrome
puisque maintenant c'est aussi la
référence ce grand axe
urbain un autre axe qui est un parc
monte vers la gare qui est très utilisé
par les habitants
on descend vers la vallée de la bièvre
dont en fait on est dans le talweg nous
disons aux sources la bièvre dans ce
secteur là et tous les quartiers autour
qui font tous plus de 1000 logements
sont autour de cet espace là qui en fait
très calme très vert et c'est vraiment
un point de convergence c'est un endroit
qui a otsi était un peu dessiné par
l'oeuvre d' une sculptrice qui est il ya
cet axe urbain à qui effectivement
l'établissement public avait confié que
marta pan on a donc dani karavan là
avait peut-être kowalski un peu plus
haut que la grande arche bleus qui est
l'entrée de la villa du vélodrome
ce sont quand même des grands noms de
l'architecturé qui on qui vont
travailler dans ce secteur
saint quentin en yvelines ville nouvelle
on dit souvent ça qu'est ce que c'est
exactement une ville nouvelle de
remonter à de gaulle à de l'ouvrier et
c'est qu'ils ont décidé que pour éviter
que paris
s'étendant tâche d'huile et décidé de
créer des points qu'ils soient pas des
morceaux de banlieue mais qu il soit des
villes réellement avec leur propre
autonomie
voilà 50 ans est un des lieux où se
retrouver des lieux où habitait de
travail voilà avec des objectifs à
l'époque très ambitieux ici en fait il y
avait déjà il n'y avait pas rien quand
on a construit la ville nous n y avait
que plusieurs communes
et comme uhnwi qui existait des communes
dans les vallées la plupart du temps les
gens ne construisait pas ne vivait pas
sans plateau au moyen âge et tout ça a
sauté trop humide c'était insalubres
alors ça a été peu à peu
drainé d'ailleurs
à l'époque de louis xiv sont en profiter
pour regrouper toute cette eau faire des
barrages comme l'étang de 50 ha pour les
grandes eaux de versailles
en
[Musique]
daniel on est dans un autre centre
névralgique à la base continuera son
pidoux qui est drôle le point principal
d'entrée de saint-quentin quand on vient
de paris par l'autoroute en dessous de
nous il y a trois ou quatre étages de
parkings parce que c'est ça qui tout a
été pensé son commercial qui est ici
tout le centre commercial souterrain de
la vipère marché souterrain les
commerces à ce niveau là donc c'est
quand même à la fois commercial de
centre commercial culturel nous avons
théâtre ici et puis mon administratif
nous n'avons pas de préfecture c'est
vrai
n'y a pas de mairie ici mais c'est quand
même une centralité fort mais tout
converge les gens le vent les
couvertures les personnes et puis la
culture était en architecture qui est
très intéressant alors alors c'est un
ensemble de trois éléments disons il ya
le théâtre vont très bien sûr en
lui-même c'est un théâtre scène
nationale
nous avons la médiathèque qui est un
outil extraordinaire aussi qui a été
conçu par le même architecte et qui est
en continuité avec le théâtre et le
musée de la ville qui est venu
d'ailleurs maintenant rejoindre la
médiathèque et a aussi ses ces
lampadaires sont là c'est incroyable ce
qu'ils me changent de forme en fonction
de delà du moment la journée ans et ça
c'est un mobilier qui est assez rare
bond qui est d'un grand designer qui a
été utilisée ici en abondance mais qui
donne aussi son caractère à la place on
peut citer un set philippe starck
exactement on voit que l'eau est
vraiment importante dans cette ville mon
là on a bien sûr la fontaine
on a traversé des espaces il y avait
aussi ce canal et puis en face là aussi
un gros plan d'eau ces terrains qui me
dit la président rennais il y avait des
canaux des rigoles ont été faites un peu
partout pour drainer ses terrains
réutiliser après au 17e
ils ont barré la vallée de la bièvre
pour faire ce film quand cinquante un
mille y avait un autre école étant à
côté c'est une ville qui a propre deux
cent mille habitants ne sais pas où vous
verrez que je sais pas mais qui n'a pas
de club donc loupé ce que l'on fait tout
et toutes les grandes villes parce que
tout un fleuve on peut évacuer les eaux
pluviales nous non donc il a fallu
mettre des bassins partout et l'idée de
l'eau et est resté très présente
ce que les urbanistes de la ville ont
appelé la trame verte et bleue qui est
qui est une réalité qui sait plus quel
slogan
c'est vrai qu'elle en impose cette
façade de théâtre et je vous propose
d'en savoir un peu plus en poussant les
portes
lionel le directeur m'a tant pour faire
le tour du propriétaire
le web on est dans un lieu qui est assez
étonnant me dire d'un point de vue
architectural on était dehors tout à
l'heure on se demandait quels étaient
les influences il ya de multiples
influences trois ou quatre à l'extérieur
quand vous avez pu le voir il ya une
référence quand même à auguste perret ce
classicisme donc espérer des choses
qu'on peut des façades qu'on peut voir
au havre par exemple il y a
vous êtes passé par rapport ce
magnifique escalier qui pourrait faire
penser au panthéon
oui mais des petites lettres justement
voix sur l'avertisseur les cerner si on
est derrière tout autour des escaliers
chacune des lettres correspond aux
initiales d'un ouvrier qui a travaillé
sur le chantier et ils ont été assez
nombreux
donc une valorisation du travail des
travailleurs et qu'on voit d'ailleurs
assure la sueur sur la petite image que
l'on a dans notre dos et puis dans la
grande salle dans laquelle on rentre à
tout à l'heure vous le verrez il ya
aussi une référence aux au teatro
olimpico de de cesena qui a été
construit
à la renaissance dessiné par vous et
théâtre olympique qui a été dessiné par
par andrea palladio un architecte de la
renaissance italienne
avec cette énorme ouverture c'était un
cadre de scène qui est assez assez grand
une salle extrêmement large donc on est
plutôt dans un théâtre romain
renaissance dont il ya cette
superposition et puis au dessus de la
façade
quand on rentre il ya darche il ya une
arche parce que le l'architecte est
originaire de gdansk en pologne en
pologne il ya bien entendu acte ans les
chantiers navals et donc il a fait une
référence à ça alors voilà il ya plein
d'influencés une référence à l'italie
une référence à wavre référence à la
pologne a été conçu en 1993 95 ha oui
donc en fait c'est quand même politique
c'est un théâtre assez récent
[Musique]
lionel emmené dans un endroit quand même
très très privilégiés qui ne fut les que
normalement par les gens qui ont le
droit d habitude on dit que c'est quand
visiter le théâtre que c'est dans cette
partie du théâtre dans cette partie des
théâtres juste en face le public que
l'on gagne de l'argent et que c'est dans
cette partie du théâtre qu'on enterre
effectivement c'est bien que c'est là
que sont les artistes mais aussi des
techniciens qui foulent ce cette saison
par exemple qui va fouler ses planches
puisque c'est des planches mais il ya
beaucoup de gens beaucoup beaucoup de
gens alors si on si on comptait en
nombre d'artistes qui m'en fous laisser
plancherait serait énorme population est
assez dense en fait cette cette salle
est avec elle avec un cadre de scène qui
correspond grosso modo à l'opéra
bastille est un des plus gros plateau
d'île de france donc c'est aussi une
salle qui appelle des formes assez voile
assez conséquente je pense
les prochaines les prochaines
représentations il va y avoir toute une
série de représentations de roméo et
juliette chorégraphe est pas rare d'y
croiser blocage là
quelques jours après il ya le
philharmonique de radio france et ses
100 musiciens qui seront là donc on
essaie aussi de développer des formes
opératique symphonique orchestrale quel
chouette aussi ici c'est vous faites
venir aussi des gens qu'on n'a pas
forcément l'habitude de voir dans un
théâtre non seulement on travaille sur
le répertoire
quelles que soient les esthétiques les
disciplines c'est aussi un travail sur
la découverte
donc il ya cette salle que vous voyez
dans laquelle nous sommes il ya
également une petite salle de 300 places
qui est qui et à l'état donc on souhaite
bien de william hill yam il peut un peu
plus de 1000 places 1040 place et en
même temps mais après ce que les gens
sont très très près ouais parce que sa
salle et est large
la salle est assez large dans sa faveur
et cette proximité
donc on alterne entre des grandes formes
qui sont volés un peu plus connus mais
pas forcément que des grandes formes
connues et puis des petites formes et
tout un travail de découverte dans
toutes les disciplines artistiques mais
c'est notre notre boulot et c'est le
travail d'une scène nationale que
d'aller découvrir des jeunes artistes
il ya aussi des ponts avec d'autres
formes de culture c'est ça il ya des
ponts avec oui d'autres la culture
scientifique
oui parce que je pars du principe que un
théâtre monde est soudé aussi un lieu
qui doit être perméable à son
environnement il se trouve que le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines se
trouve sur le plateau sur le périmètre
du plateau de saclay et le plateau de
saclay c'est un périmètre qui
concentrent j'ai pas entre 15 et 20 % de
la recherche publique et privée en
france
donc on s'est posé la question assez
rapidement de savoir comment la parole
scientifique pouvait pénétrer à
l'intérieur du d'un théâtre et on a
réussi à créer un temps
où on aborde une thématique scientifique
par le biais de la parole des
scientifiques par le biais du spectacle
vivant ça c'est notre métier notre
prochain rendez vous n'est pas loin on
va continuer notre balade dans cette
ville nouvelle en allant au musée de la
ville ça n'est pas compliqué puisque
c'est dans le même bâtiment que le
téléthon je reconnais le théâtre où on
était tout à l'heure donc maintenant on
est dans le musée c'est là c'est ça nous
on se trouve ici dans le musée au rez de
chaussée au niveau de la place s'est vu
dans un grand bâtiment qui est à la fois
théâtre que vous avez vu tout à l'heure
médiathèque et depuis 2010 est également
musée donc l'âme humaine très réservé
médiathèque un récent alors c'est un
endroit où on trouve quoi parce qu'on
voit qu'il ya des tas d'objets
différents
il ya pas mal de d'informations sur ce
qu'est la ville c'est ça c'est qu'elle
est projet de sept mois le musée a été
créé il ya
quarante ans et il est installé ici avec
un double objectif à la fois parler du
territoire et parler des modes de vie
c'est un musée qui se décompose en deux
ans deux espaces nous sommes ici dans la
salle d'exposition permanente qu'on
appelle un siècle un centre
d'interprétation de l'architecturé et du
patrimoine qui rappelle d'ailleurs que
saint quentin en yvelines si labellisée
ville d'art et d'histoire
et donc c'est un vieux qui a un espace
qui a vocation à retracer l'évolution du
territoire d origine vous voyez des
quotidiens il ya il ya aussi pas mal de
choses qui sont liées à l' architecture
art effectivement on présente le
territoire c'est-à-dire sa géographie
son architecture son urbanisme et par le
biais des collections du musée on
rappelle aussi par quelques objets
l'évolution des modes de vie notamment
sur le xxème siècle et en particulier
sur le deuxième moitié du xxème siècle
qui correspond à l'essor de la ville
nouvelle à partir des années
un peu de poésie dans ce monde urbain ça
vous dit je vous propose d'aller dans
l'atelier de nicolas sanhes nicolas
c'est un artiste du sud
installé depuis plusieurs années à saint
quentin en yvelines ici ils travaillent
les lignes les formes
ses oeuvres sont monumentales mais tout
en légèreté
adepte d'un art le plus populaire
possible ses oeuvres sont visibles pas
très loin à trappes à montélimar ou
encore à valenciennes
nicolas on est devant vingt trente
années de travail
allez 25-25 voilà donc ça vous avez
commencé par des structures comme celle
ci comme si la khl à la petite cloche
derrière la sculpture en bois noir qui
est un peu couverte de poussière
aujourd'hui c'est le cimetière de
l'acting l'activité de l'atelier
donc du coup oui c'est un travail que
j'ai fait a charrié / / / 51 devises
il ya 20 ans il est né comme ceux
d'aujourd'hui il est fait de ligne et il
est fait de petits morceaux que j'ai
coupé que gérard houllier
là c'était deux rondes aujourd'hui ce
sont des femmes qui sont pas tout à fait
qu'ils sont un peu en rond triangulaire
est ce qui est vraiment chouette dans
ces structures c'est que à la fois on
est sur quelque chose qui en métal qui
est on se doute bien que ça doit être un
peu lourd et surtout quand on voit quand
vous travaillez on ira voir tout à
l'heure mais et pourtant ça semble d'une
légèreté quand on voit le ca est rien
c'est la magie de ce travail là oui
alors ces composés de quoi exactement
ce sont des poutrelles de charpentes et
moi c'est mon matériau de prédilection
depuis maintenant près de
15e strike sur strike sur la ligne cette
sculpture qui est plutôt une sculpture
qui sculptent l'espace l'équipe a une
culture de classiques d'un cent soit la
part du sol pour aller vers l'espace moi
je la perçois suspens nu et je la pose
et c'est ce qui donne ce côté léger donc
vous partez de quoi vous quand vous
commencez vous savez déjà ce que vous
savez jamais jamais jamais ou presque
jamais ce dépens que ce sont des pièces
comme ça qui sont des pistes d'ateliers
je sais jamais pas de dessin pas de
maquette
je consommais ligne il ya près de là
semble donc il ya un travail de soudure
là en fait des différents nena au
travail de deux couples de sonneurs
d'assemblage il ya un travail très
physique ce travail de
dire industries co presque et après il
faut que tout cela tienne dans les deux
sens d'un sens plastique technique les
matériaux vous utilisez sont des
matériaux de construction des ouvrages
publics aussi enfin c'était avec des
poutrelles comme ça en acier ccd chose
faite pour accueillir du monde confond
three oui c'est la sculpture elles
viennent transformer l'espace public
elle vient l'animé elle est venue du
symbole et une sensibilité une vis
desquels véritable une véritable
politique d'acquisition d'oeuvres d'art
met une ville qui donnent une image
forte d'une certaine modernité mais en
tout cas d'un dynamisme et moi j'aime
accompagner ces milliards pour combien
de temps sa propre de faire un
championnat fort le format de la pièce
mais une grande pièce jusqu'à présent
les plus grands chantiers ccimo le
travail très impressionnant donc vous
travaillez s'agit en fait c'est ça ouais
je travaille seul
parce que ce qui ce qui est
[Musique]
dedic arabe au travail c'est qu'ils ne
peut pas être fait avec un fait avec les
maquettes du coup je suis obligée de
faire des pièces comme ça par exemple
comme celle ci mais si je vais faire une
caisse comme comme celle ci est beaucoup
plus importante
mais ce que je vais faire je vais la
numériser et dans l'idée c'est voilà on
numérise on étudiait après la nouvelle
façon de travailler pour développer des
sculptures en plus grand dans ses rangs
aujourd'hui on va pouvoir faire des
sculptures de 8,10 m 15 m nous on est
amis on a beaucoup marché alors
maintenant on va faire un peu de vélo
direction le vélodrome vous allez voir
le lieu est très impressionnant c'est
ici qu'auront lieu les épreuves des jo
de 2024
on a quand même un privilège assez
exceptionnel on est sur la côte d'azur à
saint quentin en yvelines c'est fou ça
exactement alors attention c'est la côte
d'azur du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la côte d'azur
c'est le nom technique de cette partie
bleus de la piste qui est la partie
finalement d'accélération et de
décélération grimpe sur la piste du
vélodrome d'accord on commence là et
ensuite quand on prend de la vitesse
c'est ça on monte exactement on monte
ensuite la loi 91 sur la pelouse on a
tout à fait le droit de monter sur cette
piste en bois c'est du pin de sibérie
pourquoi du pin de sibérie parce que
c'est un bois qui bouge peu finalement
on a besoin qu'il soit le plus stable
possible même si l'hydrométrie la
température sont maintenues de manière
constante dans le rhum justement pour
préserver l'état n'a piste le cyclisme
on sale c'est un sport qui est qui qui
va être beaucoup mis en valeur
d'ailleurs donc pas très très longtemps
avec vous avez accueilli des déjà des
compétitions très chouette mais vous
allez bientôt accueillir aussi les jeux
exactement nous sommes sur une piste
mais nous sommes sur la piste qui
accueillera les athlètes en 2024
c'est une grande fierté pour la france
pour le cyclisme bien sûr pour la
fédération française de cyclisme et pour
saint quentin en yvelines où nous sommes
implantés depuis maintenant en 2014
dates d'ouverture de ce vélodrome qui
est le seul rescapé en fait des projets
de la candidature de paris 2012
heureusement il a vu le jour ce qui nous
a permis d'installer notre centre
national d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france qui vient s'entraîner l'équipe de
france est là tous les jours s'entraîne
ils ont leurs ateliers techniques leur
vestiaire leur salle de muscu tout ce
qu'il faut à des athlètes de haut niveau
pour se préparer pour les grandes
compétitions dans ce vélodrome toutes
les semaines il y à des baptêmes depuis
son ouverture il ya eu plus de 10000
bakel dans ce vélodrome donc vous pouvez
venir n'importe quel moment découvrir le
cyclisme / même passé là bas c'est à
dire là où la piste ressemble plus à
quand même un mur 1dans dans les
derniers virages vraiment la piste est à
44 degrés c'est impressionnant parce que
quand on est en hausse et très haut mais
oui on apprend rapidement à monter et
lors des baptêmes qu'ils soient publics
ou d'entreprises par exemple
rares sont les gens qui arrivent pas à
monter et on voulait jusqu'à quelle
vitesse mathieu alors on roule les
champions roule jusqu'à 80 kilomètres
heure dans les compétitions de vitesse
pure fait traîner on va tout enroulée
entre 25 et 35 km heure et c'est déjà
très bien oui c'est déjà ya moyen de se
faire un petit peu un petit peu peur à
une fac te ment et donc ici s'est passé
un truc assez chouette avec un os x
s'appelle robert notre ami robert oui
alors passé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire il ya 105 ans il fait
toujours du cyclisme et il fait
décidément sur piste et il bat des
records alors il est seul dans sa
catégorie vous me direz mais il établit
le record mais depuis l'ouverture de ce
vélodrome il s'est passé des choses
merveilleuses puisqu'un an après son
ouverture en 2015 ont accueilli les
championnats du monde c'est un événement
fantastique avec un public hystérique en
cinq jours beaucoup de médailles pour
l'équipe de france l'année qui suit à
qui a suivi des championnats d'europe
on va accueillir prochainement une
manche de coupe du monde l'année
prochaine donc on fait tout ce qu'il
faut pour peaufiner les réglages
finalement être prêt pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 et puis bien sûr
donner la chance aux spectateurs de
devoir les plus belles compétitions les
plus grands champions sur notre piste à
50 ans de vie oui c'est un équipement
qui est assez exceptionnel bon vous
l'avez dit il est très récent et puis il
est premier de sa catégorie dans pas mal
de domaines dgid dehors il ya une piste
de bmx c'est ça exactement qui est
couverte d'une piste de bmx couvertes ce
qui nous permet en ile-de-france de
pouvoir
s'entraîner toute l'année ça c'est
merveilleux et juste de l'autre côté de
l'île de loisirs qui est notre voisine
oui on voit d'ailleurs étoiles all et
les plans d'eau doyen paul acquis à
plein de choses sympas et un parcours de
golf de l'accrobranche enfin c'est un
super centre il ya l'autre côté de la
colline d'elancourt qui est le plus haut
point de l'île de france et qui sera
aménagé pour le vtt
donc pour les jeux olympiques en 2024
aucun temps l'ex trois des quatre
disciplines de cyclisme se dérouleront
ici la piste le bmx et le vtt
mais on sera tous derrière vous derrière
la fédération du secteur cyclisme merci
beaucoup
avec plaisir c'est au vélodrome que
s'achève notre première journée à saint
quentin en yvelines
vous vous doutez bien qu'il reste encore
beaucoup de choses à voir le prochain
épisode sera beaucoup plus nature juste
avant de se quitter je vous laisse avec
notre série sur les pièces de la monnaie
de paris
et nous voici à paris parly universel
pour jean paul gaultier qui a dessiné
cette pièce de 10 euros de la monnaie de
paris s'inscrit dans cette série la
france par jean paul gaultier et donc
c'est la vision d'abord de jean paul
gaultier mai à paris si vous parlez de
paris dans le monde entier c'est la tour
eiffel c'est le monument le plus visité
au monde dont on ne pouvait pas faire
une pièce sur paris sans avoir la tour
eiffel
mais évidemment une tour eiffel stylisé
une tour eiffel revisité par jean paul
gaultier
mais voilà c'est le symbole de paris
évidemment il y a tout paris dans cette
pièce a d'abord ya un livret sur lequel
on voit une femme
cette femme qui regarde en tout cas se
révèlent sur lequel elle va il ya les
tatouages qui représente paris et puis
il ya marqué il ya la sorte de soleil
avec le pari universel le pari universel
au féminin alors qu'est ce qu'on voit
sur cette pièce est évidemment les
autres symboles de paris au pouvoir
notre dame va voir l'arc de triomphe
et puis la tour eiffel la tour eiffel
stylisée par jean paul gaultier
bah c'est évidemment une femme une femme
avec des talons avec ses hommes avec son
corps ces femmes qui enjambe la seine
quelque chose qui me charme qui attire
et peut-être y prend aussi le pouvoir à
jean paul gaultier a décidé cette pièce
jean paul gaultier
on connaît le grand couturier qui l'est
c'est l'homme qui est le premier mis des
jupes ou sommes donc c'est un
provocateur dans le bon sens du terme et
sa vision de la tour eiffel qui est
devenue maintenant classique même les
siennes d'aix en 25 ans que à l'époque
où elle a été érigée à la choquer ville
a beaucoup de monde elle était elle
aussi révolutionnaire c'est une vision
révolutionnaire de cette tour eiffel
c'est la vision du couturier les
couturiers qu'est-ce qu'il faut une amie
il habille les femmes il habille aussi
les monuments et transforme les
monuments en femme là où l'album abba
c'est un cadeau voilà je vais garder
précieusement d'avoir d'abord parce que
j'ai une grande admiration pour jean
paul gaultier une amitié pour jean paul
gaultier et ensuite parce que je trouve
que oui elle représente ce que j'avoue
de paris c'est-à-dire une ville qui
n'est pas figée dans ses monuments
qu'une ville qui bouge une ville qui vit
une ville qui invente et et voilà c'est
donc la garder précieusement dans ma
collection
pour l'instant la valeur nominale c'est
10 euros c'est à dire qu'on va acheter
cette pièce 10 euros moi je vous fiche
mon billet comme dit quelqu'un
d'important que dans quelques années ça
vaudra peut-être plus de 10 euros
ça sera un bon c'est donc un cadeau
formidable affaire à des enfants à
quelqu'un qui vous est cher
dans le prochain épisode direction
l'ouest et la bretagne des pièces de
monnaie à collectionner ou à offrir à
retrouver dans vos bureaux de poste chez
les buralistes participant à l'opération
et bien sûr sur monet de paris.fr
[Musique]
les savoir faire de la monnaie de paris
vous accompagne en terre de france
[Musique]